your book is is pretty much a diary some
of it facts some of it fiction right
of your account of what's happened to
you is that right half of it's fiction
and then the other half of it is things
taken from my diary that have been on
the radio right and it's stuff that's
that has really
which is true for example you say while
you're writing the book and why you're
doing the radio show at the same time
you clean apartments for a living is
that true i i work for a house cleaning
company so i clean apartments maybe four
days a week really now tell me what
that's like i mean do you have to do
that anymore is it something that you
know that you do to make money or is it
something that you do well i write
therapeutic in any way i write in the
evening because it doesn't feel right to
drink that much during the day so this
is a good job for me in the daytime and
it gives me a place to go and it gets me
out of the house uh-huh when you say you
clean the apartments i mean how
thoroughly do you clean them you do the
whole um i don't i don't iron but i do
just about everything else
my favorite job right now is this couple
who has a huge apartment on the upper
west side nicest people in the world
very smart and they don't
have a clue like i find unspeakable
things in their apartment like
silverware that looks like it was
crafted out of human hair and uh
last time i was there the vacuum cleaner
was clogged so i put it the hose to my
mouth like a trumpet and i realized too
late that they had been vacuuming out
the litter box
which was uh
why did you pretend it was a trumpet
clear now to clear it out
yeah i find unspeakable things in their
home so that's my favorite job just
because every time i go i i can't
imagine what they're up to this time
like the things that they use for
ashtrays like uh
they cramped the middle of a toothpaste
tube and used that for an ashtray
uh
let me ask you quickly do they know now
that you're on tv telling about their
private sick fascinations no no they
they don't uh okay i don't know what i
do oh good now what's what's the easiest
house for you to clean uh there's a
german couple who comes to new york
three days out of the year and they want
their apartment cleaned once a week and
they had a decorator do every do it and
everything's white the carpet's white
the furniture's white all the food in
the refrigerator is white
the mugs are white everything so i just
go take off my shoes and watch tv for
three hours there's really nothing else
for me to
that's not a bad and what do you get
then how much is that for the whole i
get ten dollars an hour and then my
master takes five of that so the whole
thing is 15 an hour that's not bad yeah
just for watching tv for light dusting
that that's not bad at all have you ever
found something incredibly you know evil
and you know where you realize this
person's a serial killer i better get
out of here i was cleaning someone's
house and i saw a little little
packet a little uh whole you know little
thing under the bed and i was lifting it
to clean and it opened and a big gun
fell into my lap and that was the
scariest thing i found and you just did
you take it and start committing crimes
with it or just put it back well i put
it back but then i then i i started
vacuuming and i thought i guess i should
go back and clean my fingerprints off
that gun as if as if i had good that's
like a real new york attitude you touch
a gun i better get my prince off that
fast now you were uh you were also you
talking the or you mentioned on the
radio and you're talking in the book you
were an elf at macy's that was my first
job when i moved to new york now what is
that job like what does it entail uh
there's like a week-long training
session before you can be an elf and you
have to take a battery of psychiatric
tests to show that you're not a lunatic
and then you're given a green velvet
costume and put your work
once they determine that you're not
insane you're not a lunatic and you
learn how to use the cash register and
you learn to say a few little things in
sign language and uh and then there's a
training you act it out in a training
seminar and then you you start work and
it's a magnificent job it's just to work
in any kind of a big store for the
holidays or i think if you worked at a
theme park you'd get the same you you
see everything you like that i mean it's
it's supposed to be hellish you know to
be in a big department store like macy's
on the holiday what's good you're in an
elf costume you're handling kids
that's two good things um
uh
just just to see what
what people expect or what what goes on
like i mean i think people worry that
they don't live in a democratic nation
if they're waiting in line for more than
three hours and especially if you're
waiting in line to see santa but just
the things people would do like uh
you'd see a mother unzip her sons fly
and have him urinate into a bank of
artificial snow as if
as if this were outdoors and those those
are real stars on the ceiling things
like that
you see so you probably see the parents
do a lot of weird things right yeah well
a lot of times the parents would say
okay okay rachel tell santa what you
want tell them what you want tell them
you want a baby alive and tell them you
want and they name everything that
they've already bought they don't want
the child to say they want a pony or uh
anything that they that the parents
haven't already
gotten for the child so are parents so
the parents really coach them on what to
say to santa
you know they'll have a child do like a
little act for santa saying something
for santa or
mainly it was disappointing because it
was the same thing over and over and
over again yeah you know people saying
the exact same things
but
um and then i would take pictures of the
children with santa and that was because
you were a special elf your job was to
take photos you'd have like seven or
eight jobs like you might be a water
cooler elf and just stand near the water
cooler for a while going like this
and then you might be a magic winter
wind window elf and you would say can
you step on the magic star and look to
the window and you can see santa and
then you do that for hours and hours and
hours
but taking the photographs was fun
because i don't know people would say
smile
and that was acceptable i don't know
where but i always wondered where did
people learn to do that and i guess i
saw
it's like they're sitting on something
like as if they were broken glass or
something in the seat the smiles that
people would would manufacture well very
few people smile naturally when they're
told to smile by an elf you know yeah
it's not what comes to mind naturally
well it's a very funny book and of
course the radio show is doing great so
you're you're happy life is good uh yeah
i can't complain yeah well thanks very
much for being here with us david
sedaris everybody thanks a lot for
coming